好,我們今天來講一個夜盤當充策略
最近夜盤真的很好賺
波動超大的,真的打得很爽
所以來跟大家講一下
我每天都會操作的夜盤當充策略
那今天是禮拜天,我們講禮拜五的盤
禮拜五是台子騎收在16356
然後加權指數是收在16408
就是跟大家講一下背景
然後夜盤是下午3點開盤
這個大家應該知道吧
那就一直到這個
4點26分這個地方
都還沒什麼可以進出場的訊號
沒有這個策略可以進出場的訊號
然後到這邊的時候
突然出現了一個爆大量
就是一個超爆大量的多單
然後呢
又出現了一個繼續爆大量
直接打到了16400
那像這種爆大量的K棒
它是往上爆大量的K棒
那它的低點就會是一個支撐
這個再往上爆大量,那它的低點也是一個支撐
那為什麼這些是有意義的支撐
就是因為如果這個低點被跌破
如果你說這個低點是
你說這個低點是16368
那這個368跌破
只要出現367
那就表示這個755口的人全部都在輸前
那所有人都在輸前
就可能會有人停順嘛
而且也表示這些單子防守
防守失敗了
所以
就是低點367就會是一個有意義的價位
那這個
這個K棒的低點是
所以如果出現392的價格的話
非常適合空單進場
然後這時候我剛好是
坐在電腦前
眼睛看盤
所以
而且這個單
另一個非常好的點是
它打到16400
整數關卡
然後再往下轉折
所以出現了16392
我就馬上空單進場
那就
那我按下去
這個成交是在16394
那這個空單
就非常好
因為我停損就只要抓
16400的突破
那我就抓10點停損
那
停力呢
停力我就可以抓很遠
因為
停力是
至少要是停損的2到3倍嘛
那我停損10點
停力就至少可以20到30點
但是20到30點停力
的地方又剛好會再疊破這一個支撐
就是
我剛說的16367
的支撐
所以你的停力又可以再抓更遠
因為你在這個地方停力就本質上是
在這個支撐被疊破的地方又打多單
那這樣不合理嘛
所以你停力又可以再拉更遠
那例如說
呃
這一次我是拉60點的停力
就是
前面的這個
震盪下來震盪下來的這個低點是
332嘛
我覺得大概抓60點
那
就是在16334的地方停力
好我們就繼續往下看
然後後來就
就一路往下跌
所以就
這筆單就滿成功的
就成功停力到
停力到那邊
哎呦
看一下
哦在這邊
就是剛好到
到334的地方
然後就反彈了
就是跟前面的低點是在
類似的位置
就是
剛好到這邊的前低
然後
反彈上去
所以這單就
成功的收下了60點
然後這一單是
打下去的時候
我就覺得
哇
這一單這個
天時地義人和
同時
是兩根
是一根長紅
之後的一個短的紅
然後收一個上影線
然後
而且這上影線還收的沒有很長
大概10點左右
就是一個非常舒服的停損
他讓我停損可以很短
然後停力
因為這個連續兩根
停力就可以很長
那你看我如果手10點的停損
60點的停力
那是1:6嘛
所以我
我輸一次
呃
就是我
我贏一次可以輸6次
所以7次成功一次
我這筆單就賺了
那
如果我
例如說我覺得這個筆單的勝率有個
30%
那我這就是一個超級正期望值的操作
然後另外一個是
因為這剛好是16400
所有的零零結尾都是
自然而然的壓力支撐點位
就是在自由人的中年大數操盤法裡面也是
所有的零零結尾
100倍數也都是
這個
他們是說整數關卡啦
不過因為每個數字都是整數嘛
反正就是100倍數的關卡
那
而且這件事情是有科學的
心理學的根據的
就是在
2021年的
美國的潘泥百貨
他就
曾經
他的執行長就把
所有
就是
例如說
38.99
或者是
這個
99.99
元
美金的價格
全部那個99都改成
最接近的整數
99.99元就改成100元
49.99元就改成
50元
然後跟大家說那個
那個
那個0.1美分根本就沒差
結果
潘泥百貨的
銷售量就
大暴跌
然後他的股價也大暴跌
然後那個
執行長就被
趕下台
就是
這件事情是有
行為經濟學的理論支持的
就是你們感受一下
這個
跟500
的差距
還有
比如說
312跟313
給你的
感覺的差距
你會覺得
312跟313
差不多是差不多的數字
就是
你沒辦法那麼感受到他的差異
但
499跟500
他的差異會是更大一點
但其實比例來說
312跟313差的比較少嘛
那
就是
這個是有心理學的
的根據支持的
然後
另外當然也是
加權收在408嘛
那所以這邊也是
就是
雙重的這個壓力位置
然後剛好這邊又是一個
支撐的跌破
所以這一單是
算是一個很經典
然後也很單純
中間也沒有再重新爆打量
然後就
成功的停立在
這個
前滴的地方
所以這個算是
這個策略最
最基礎
最沒有
奇怪分支變化的
的一個情況
好那
反正
就是
394口嘛
然後不再334
然後今天是5月8號
但是我卻交易到了
5月9號的日期
是因為
就是夜盤就開始算是
下一天了
那這是禮拜五的夜盤嘛
那下一個交易日就是禮拜一
所以他日期是明天的日期
這個也都是很
自然的一些小嘗試
然後我做了一個
簡單的圖解
就是16400這邊
是停損的點
就是超過16400
只要出現16401
就停損
然後
這一個
這個
1640年
這一根紅K棒
低一點
減1
出現空彈進場
然後
就
我這邊是抓60點停立
剛好就停立在
這個前滴的附近
然後後來盤就反彈了
那下面圈起來這個是爆大量的位置
大家可以
可以
稍微理解一下這個
這個算是
最基礎的一個變化
然後
我們看一下後面
後面發生的事情好了
就是
禮拜五後來就
就到這邊都一直沒有爆大量
要到8點多的時候
才又再又再有出量
然後像這種交易啊
就是
你的單進場之後
其實你可以就
就挂出價停損停立
然後
你就不需要一直坐在電腦前嘛
不然後面這兩個小時
什麼時候沒發生
這個
其實中間就
你可以去睡覺去吃飯啊
其實都沒什麼差
然後這邊出現了
一根超級
長的紅K
這是爆大量嘛
所以我們剛說了嘛
暴大量長紅K的低點
會是
這個
就是
如果突破的時候
可以
空單進場
所以這個低點是
338嘛
那所以337可以
這個空單進場
然後
停損可以守
371的突破
就是372
所以就是一個
35點的停損
但如果你要打35點的停損
那你的停力就至少要70點
那
那你要打的口數就要小一點
例如說你平常是打
三口大台
那就改成一口大台
那
才不會讓你的停損
就是太大
然後
好
那這個低點沒有被疊破嘛
然後又一直往上
然後又出現了一個
這個
害得要被爆雷
就是
又出現了一個爆大量的長紅K
然後他的低點是不是又被疊破
他的低點是
然後這邊出現打到了369
所以在369的地方
觸加空單進場
然後停損是守多少
就是
16381嘛
對不對
一個12點的停損
然後呢
然後過了幾秒鐘之後
16381停損
對吧
因為
他又又重新突破了嘛
那所以
這400口的人
全部就又在贏錢了
那他們從全部輸錢又變成都在贏錢
那你空單進場的理由就消失了嘛
所以在380+1381的地方就停損
然後再往下呢
結果
停損在最高點
是不是很賭啦
其實還好
這就是
本來就會發生了正常的事情
看起來好像停損在最高點
但是
那你是不是就說那以後就不要停損了
我們多看個5點
是不是就沒事了
絕對不是這樣
你每一次都多看5點
你就每一次都多損5點
你每次損單就會因此多損
所以
不要因為這一次你損在381
然後你以後就
就是
那我以後多看個5點
那你每次多損5點
長期下來
你正期望值的策略就被你打成負期望值
好
我們剛剛說這個
下面是下一個支撐嘛
所以337
出現的話
空單還是可以重新進場
所以在這邊337的地方
空單又重新進場
然後呢
然後就
有
欸這個衝上來是不會停損的喔
因為譬如說
你停損是抓372嘛
那這邊這個小震盪是
是都不會停損
然後
然後到
這邊是
這個9點半是每股開盤
那每股開盤的千幾分鐘
這個交易量就會
開始放大
就跟台股的千幾分鐘一樣
那每股在震盪
台股當然也會跟著震盪
這個9點半
這個
出量然後震盪
是很正常的事情
然後剛剛是說337
到
372嘛
所以是35點停損的話
至少是70點停利
所以至少是
定利在267
那這一單也是成功停利到70點
然後
按太快又把大家爆雷
然後這個
這個
這邊是反方向嘛
對不對
這個是
低點是
然後高點是
那所以這邊是跌破空單進場嗎
不是喔
這個一定是
掌過這一個
綠K的高點
多單進場
因為是跟那個是對稱的嘛
是
掌過這個高點
這整個K棒的全部人
都在輸錢
所以你贏過他們
他們可能停損
或者是其他原因
反正
就是他們不防守
加上開始輸錢
那就有可能是行情反轉的開始
我們講過很多次嘛
進場在
趨勢開始反轉的時候
好
所以在這邊
這個
多單進場
然後呢
然後馬上就
在這邊就停損了
對不對
在這個地方就
就停損了
這個地方有停損嗎
喔有
這邊有到
沒有耶
到23
這邊還沒有停損
好
下一個可以幫
229出現
就停損
就是多單停損
然後
再往下
這根本身也是一個
爆大量嘛
所以他的低點
他的低點是
那他低點是225
空單又可以重新進場
然後
然後空單重新進場到
這個爆大量又被跌破
但也是在打空單的訊號
所以沒有差
然後
這一個
綠K的
高點被掌過了
這個是剛好有打到
這個是205
這個
這個高點也是205
所以這個地方
應該是在過
一兩分鐘
下
這邊
206的地方
這個空單就被打出去了
在這邊
在這邊的話
還是挺利
因為剛剛是225空
然後這邊
206再重新躲
那
到這邊就是
開始要來回
來回多空對翻啦
就比較複雜一點
好
然後
這邊又可以再賺到一筆很長的多單
就是在
這一個
漲過的時候
是一個多單進場訊號
所以空單是直接停利
然後
對翻變成多單進場
那
206進場
然後停損是守在
這個
192的地方
然後
就是
從這個地方
多單進場
停損點又沒有被打到
然後又
重新賺到了一個
從186往上滴的這一段
好
反正就是
來回賺啦
禮拜五真的是
真的是賺很爽
真的是好賺一直賺
賺錢就是這麼簡單
好不好
如果你會數學的話
賺錢就是這麼簡單
然後
好吧
整理一下今天
幾個
幾個重點
就是
爆大量
的紅K
低點跌破
空單進場
然後
停損就是高點
爆大量的
綠K
高點長過
就是
多單進場
停損就守低點
然後
所有的
00的整數關卡
都會是
自然而然的
支撐壓力
那當然
昨天日盤的高點
昨天日盤的低點
昨天日盤的收盤價
昨天日盤的價錢指數位置
這些也都是
關鍵的
關鍵的一些
沉壓位置
好
然後
當然
還是有很多
就是像後面
就是一直多空對反啊
然後
或者是
你人工去
調整
停損跟停力的位置啊
然後
就
就是
其實人工看的話
還是會
會有一些
可以調整的好處啊
但是
其他分支變化就
就之後再
有機會再講吧
好
影片時間也差不多了
應該大家也學到很多吧
好
就這樣啦
希望大家
可以跟我一起賺錢
拜拜